[Musique]
invité de s'organise ce matin marcellin
nadeau le maire du prêcheur bonjour
marcellin nadeau bonjour alain livory
bonjour des tris aux auditeurs de matin
première radio toute l'équipe de la
matinale
je voudrais quand même adresser mes plus
sincères condoléances à la famille de
gabriel gagnon dont je salue la mémoire
c'est un journaliste d'un
professionnalisme vraiment un homme
extraordinaire avec qui on avait des
froids des discussions très
intéressantes nomme très cultivé qui a
marqué sa profession que bon voyage et
géo gamme accès à l'ivg il ya le galion
très bien quelle lecture vous faites
marcellin nadeau de la crise à la
septième date consterné bon consterné ça
n'est pas le mot je pense qu'il faut
toujours quand on est militant politique
regarder les choses avec le sang-froid
qui convient mais je crois que quand
même si c'est regrettable
je pense que dans un pays comme le nôtre
un pays avec notre configuration de
notre dimension
je vois que c'est le type de
fonctionnement qu'on devrait être de
dysfonctionnements plutôt qu'on devrait
éviter
je crois que nous en tant qu'élu parce
que j'ai quand même participé à au
travail d'élaboration en quelque part du
projet de collectivité unique parce que
j'étais la commission ad-hoc nous avions
souhaité justement qu'une vraie
dynamique démocratique dynamique
démocratique qui s'appuyait sur deux
piliers un conseiller exécutif collégial
même si un président bien sûr et de leur
côté une assemblée avec toutes ses
prérogatives ou pourrait régner une
ambiance de travail de respect mutuel
qu'on en arrive là
non mais ça dit que nous avions déjà
tiré la sonnette d'alarmé déjà bon
je serai avec eux je veux dire en phase
un peu avec le professeur justin daniel
nous peuple à s'organiser très tôt une
réflexion bon à l'époque le président de
l'assemblée de martinique semblait dire
que non tout allait bien il semble être
dans le déni à l'époque aujourd'hui le
reconnaît effectivement des réalités
bons qui sont dus effectivement comme il
l'a très bien expliqué aux imperfections
de la loi mais qui sont également dues à
un problème de pratique pas ce que nous
disions le peuple a aussi qui ne suffit
pas d'avoir un cadre institutionnel
il faut aussi avoir des sommes qui
seront en mesure de développer des
pratiques institutionnelles
donc je crois que le conseil exécutif et
le président a pris le pas sur
l'assemblée ce qui n'est pas une bonne
chose
alors que l'assemblée telle qu'elle est
conçue pouvait être un espace
extraordinaire de réflexion de
prospection d'évaluation il y avait une
dynamique démocratique à crier et
malheureusement voit les choses partir
en eau de boudin comme qui dirait à l'
approche de noël que lisa à raison de
rester moi je ne sais pas c'est à lui
d'apprécier mon ce que lui a dit qu'il
le fait pour éviter une crise s'il
s'agit effectivement d'éviter une crise
dans ce jeu ne réjouit pas de cette
situation personne ne plus rejouer cette
situation parce que effectivement ça
peut entraîner une crise pour le pays où
son développement et à des gens qui
attendent la mise en oeuvre de
politiques publiques
et puis en plus c'est vrai que quelque
part nous pouvons être d'une part la
risée du monde de se dire parce qu'il ya
des gens qui espèrent qu'ils espéraient
qu'ils escomptaient de voir se
développer cette expérience nous avons
notamment rencontré grâce aux au cnfpt
mère d'alsace qui était conseiller
régional conseiller communautaire et
caetera et qui nous disaient qu'ils te
qui a des qui développe une expérience
intéressante de démocratie participative
qui ne disait qu'il qu'il comptait
qu'ils observaient beaucoup le
fonctionnement de la collectivité unique
parce qu'il souhaitait une collectivité
unique pour sa région d'alsace
voyez donc les gens nous regardent et
puis aussi la population l'opinion
publique martiniquaise moi je suis un
partisan de la responsablité
martiniquaise en tant que souverainiste
mais les gens quand ils voient ce qui se
passe eh bien on risque de discréditer à
jamais l'idée même de responsabilité
martiniquaise et la petite mare l'heure
où la pacifiste et de souveraineté de
responsabilité que nous avons gagné à
travers cette expérience de créativité
territoriale et bien nous risquons
effectivement de la dilapider à l'heure
où il est difficile de mobiliser pour
aux élections
bon après les élections et c'est comme
ça comme l'ambitionne parfait sur sur
l'image du haut mais avec une image de
l'homme martin qui est générale d'app on
a des réalités politiques qui ne sont
pas propres à la martinique je veux dire
que il ya effectivement dans un certain
nombre de partis aujourd'hui qui les
parties deviennent obsolètes
quand j'entends aussi de l'autre côté
des deux groupes hall en fait de 7,2 de
ses qui structurent notre paysage
politique de l'heure tout est bon le
leader de l'open dit oh que bon on peut
me remplace pas le vide par le vide on
va y revenir tout ça ce sont des propos
que je trouve effectivement un petit peu
d'une certaine arrogance et je crois
qu'il faut revenir à plus d'humilité
plus de modestie en politique et il faut
que l'homme politique change de posture
qui se rendent compte que face à la
complexité des réalités il faut cliquer
douce clim hall puis respectueux de
notre seuil on à l'autre nos gars
comprennent que nous c'est
l'intelligence collective qui a du sens
politique à mon avis bloc monégasque dit
libéral alors moi je crois que il faut
absolument qu'ils aient des martiniquais
se rassemblent effectivement je pense et
ce que nous avons le feu nous voulons
faire évoluer à nous peuple ah non mais
je trouve dans la crise l'actuel la
crise gaumont gens trop bon ça dit que
j'espère bien que les choses vont
revenir à la normale ça dès qu'ils ont
un diallo qui va se nouer dans l'intérêt
que les personnes ne s'aiment pas ça
c'est leur problème c'est pas ça qui est
question mais que les gens sauront faire
preuve de responsabilité puisque en
parle de responsabilité martiniquaise et
b que chaque chacun des acteurs saura
faire preuve de responsabilité pour
trouver la voie du dialogue et rétabli
un fonctionnement normal mais que cette
crise ne sera pas en quelque part
inutile qu'elle s'assoit fertile fierté
dans le sens où on est mais j'espère
bien quand même que le président du
conseil exécutif que les membres du
conseil exécutif prendront conscience de
la nécessité de changer leurs pratiques
alors si cette crise à travers le
dialogue déboucher sur un règlement des
dysfonctionnements qui déjà là la crise
est là et elle explose aujourd'hui
merris aliciens les conditions de la
crise états unis mais j'espère
effectivement de cette faiblesse que la
ctm soit faire sa force
j'espère vraiment alors vous en avez un
peu parlé
et une offre politique nouvelle on parle
beaucoup du g20 on dit que vous faites
partie de ceux de ce rassemblement
vous en faites partie alors moi je suis
pas je dis qu'il faut éviter aussi le
jeu ni validé que bombe parce qu'il voit
des jeunes forcément tout ira bien moi
je crois qu'il faut un renouvellement de
la classe politique
pas seulement sur la question de l'âge
la question aussi de la présence des
femmes
nous avons une bombe était une petite
évolution avec des députés des
sénatrices et c'est bon c'est bien mais
nous avons quand même une classe
politique est fortement masculinisées
est assez âgée dans l'ensemble et c'est
vrai que comme des gens comme boon est
eurazeo disent qu'ils font
renouvellement de la classe politique
et il a raison il a fondamentalement
raison sauf que il faut aussi un
équilibre il faut que la classe
politique soit l'image de la société
qu'il y ait des femmes des hommes des
personnes plus âgées - âgés plus jeunes
etc
non je crois qu'il faut qu'il faut ça il
faut second nouvelle monnaie et
maintenant s'agissant du rassemblement
que j'appelle de mes voeux
selon la formule d'aimé césaire n'est ce
pas opté pour le plus large contre le
plus étroit je crois quand même qu'il
faut que ça parte de projet politique
il s'agit pas non plus de rassembler des
hommes et 1 cela peut-être que le
président du ppm a raison rassembler des
hommes pour rassembler des hommes
il s'agit de réfléchir un véritable
projet est de rassembler toutes celles
et tous ceux qui pourraient se mettre
d'accord sur un minimum de choses il
faut sauver le soldat s'était m on l'a
compris que ça peut être un modèle de
démocratie on a compris que est bien
celle de personnes ne comprennent pas
l'intérêt qu'il y avait une véritable
dynamique démocratique il faut changer
le nom miniature comme il peut y avoir
entre un républicain deux équipes en
lice
ce qui vous a parlé de république et non
moi je crois que justement faux-pas
faical à la fois parfaite celle là il
faut aussi on rassemble dijon rassemble
des gens sur des valeurs sûres un projet
politique clair le projet pour lequel
serait supposé projet politique qui peut
passer par exemple à la question de la
démocratie c'est fondamental mais qu'est
ce que les jeunes peuvent y eu ni
complot ni complot chine ne fait pas la
décence
il ya plusieurs aspects la relation
entre majorité opposition
la relation entre exécutif à eux
organe délibérant la relation entre
syndicats et dirigeants politiques
la relation entre technostructure
c'est-à-dire administratifs techniciens
et politique
nous avons à bâtir et je crois que s'il
ya des imperfections au niveau de la loi
bon qu'on les corrige mais on n'a pas
besoin d'une loi pour organiser ses
relations ses relations pour être
organisée au travers d'une chat non
pourrait se douter la ctm toute instance
confondues je vous parle encore du g20
le givet ce qu'on résume on l'appliqué
martinique perspective moment est-ce que
ça doit être ouvert à la droite
également
moi je c'est à dire que je crois qu'il
faut des valeurs cette décla lors il
faut pas peut-être tout de suite dire
doigt de gauche il faut interroger les
gens sur des valeurs est ce qu'on est
on remet en cause la logique néolibérale
qui appauvrit est-ce qu'on remet en
cause la question des inégalités
territoire est-ce qu'on remet en cause
la question de la dépendance alimentaire
est-ce qu'on remet en cause la question
de la dépendance énergétique est ce
qu'on est prêt à respecter les droits
des travailleurs est ce qu'on est prêt à
ce qu'il y ait plus de respect des
droits des femmes etc
c'est une série de questions qu'il faut
poser et rassembler des gens tout d'un
projet peut-être pas a priori exclure je
crois qu'il faut éviter les
soustractions et aller plus dans la
logique des additions et moi je crois
qu'à partir de là on peut ont pu
rassembler seul s'agissant du g20 je
dois dire que le g20 m n'a jamais
fondamentale exister c'est quelqu'un qui
appeler ça comme ça et du g20 si on peut
appeler ça comme ça je m'en suis détaché
pourquoi parce que certains voulaient
rattacher le wagon gît 20 locomotives
letchimy d'autres voulaient rattacher le
wagon g20 à la locomotive marie-jeanne
même a dit mme en patience à ce que je
voulais ouvrir des perspectives ou une
troisième fois on peut appeler ça comme
ça mais en rassemblement citoyen autour
d'un projet qui propose une alternative
pas une alternance tire toi là que je
m'y mette
mais une alternative pour mener à bien
les affaires de ce pays dans l'intérêt
du peuple martiniquais
on poursuit notre interview la chambre
régionale des comptes vous donne un bon
point
vous sortez de la zone rouge jeu
vous en tant qu' en tant que ville du
prix du prêcheur primaires de la ville
du prêcheur la ville se disant dit et
vous avez réussi votre pari oui mais
nous avons réussi notre pari nous nous
avons marqué des points nous avons
avancé grâce je le dois le dire aussi
aalla aux concessions vieux dira aux
efforts faits par les agents municipaux
je dois aller saluer aux élus qui
pendant quatre ans sont restés sans
percevoir leurs indemnités à la
population qu'ils acceptent une somme
d'obstacles et fils mais les fouilles
des abris fragile et fragile a dit que
c'est un malade convalescent il s'agit
surtout pas de baisser lac à la garde du
moins mais il faut poursuivre ses
efforts pour retrouver un équilibre
durable des finances de la commune de
triche dernier point vous avez participé
en haïti aux deuxièmes assises de la
coopération décentralisée franco
haïtienne et cela va peut-être déboucher
vers la création d'une union d de la can
tout à fait donc c'est le maire de
carrefour en haïti donc à l'invitation
du capital et pour rencontrer la mère de
chuck tu avec lequel on doit développer
un projet de coopération qui a proposé
cette union des collectivités caribéenne
je suis avec athanase jeanne rose pierre
samot kit est aussi membre d'une sorte
de comité de suivi avait aussi des gens
de guadeloupe penchard le maire de
pointe-à-pitre bangou et c'est donc dans
notre esprit c'est de crier vraiment une
dynamique entre collectivités de la
caraïbe véritable échange entre des
études et que des problématiques
essentielles qui nous concerne comme la
question des risques naturels
aujourd'hui nous sommes tous confrontés
nous un beau même bateau à nous soucier
à bayonne mais nous non jeudi la bomba
toi donc il faut savoir coopérer pour
trouver ensemble des solutions parce que
l'intelligence et la chose qui est de la
lah plus là la mieux partagée au monde
on n'a pas l'exclusivité de
l'intelligence il faut la partager avec
nos voisins de la caraïbe d'offrir de la
caraïbe mercy marcellin nadeau
excellente journée à l écoute de nos
programmes c'est moi merci au revoir